[Music]
hey everyone it's katie i hope you guys
are doing well i am still social
distancing and i really want to make
some sourdough bread but i'm not really
an expert my friend marissa is
so i thought we could try to virtually
bake together and she can teach us her
beginner sourdough bread recipe i'm
gonna give her a call right now and
we'll see how it goes plus i desperately
i miss people i miss hanging out with
other people
hey hi katie how are you
i'm good so i guess you're just gonna
like walk us through this virtually of
course i'm ready can you just tell us
what tools we need to get started yeah
everything can be like modified
depending on what you have in your
kitchen so don't be scared off i'm gonna
make it in a glass bowl today if you
have a medium-sized plastic lidded
container that also works really well
too to keep the heat in i also have on
hand a bench scraper a rubber spatula a
food scale if you don't have a food
scale get some measuring cups and spoons
out a sharp paring knife or a bread lawn
the proofing basket if you don't have a
bread proofing basket you can take a
medium-sized bowl and line it with a
cotton towel for baking need a
dutch oven with a lid
if you don't have any of those you could
bake in an open cast iron pan a
combo cooker or a loaf pan okay i am
gonna go grab all my stuff and i will be
i'll meet you back here i'm excited i'm
excited
all right we're back i'm here with
marissa over here hello
so the first thing you want to do is put
your bowl on a food scale if you have
one and tear it which means you're
setting the scale to zero
first step we're gonna get warm water
and measure 400 grams into the bowl
we're doing it at the same time it's so
fun
it's like we're hanging out
the next step is adding your mature
starter to the water i have fed this
last night
right before going to bed and now we're
baking right in the morning so it's been
about eight hours i also have my own
starter that i just made last week with
marissa's health you guys can check out
that video if you want to make a starter
from scratch and this acts as like the
lemon for the bread like naturally
leavened bread okay so the next step is
to add your mature active starter to the
water we're gonna do 100 grams 100 grams
baby so now we can use our spatula to
dissolve the starter boom done the next
step is that we're going to add 400
grams of bread flour and 100 grams of
whole wheat flour great so then are you
going to use a spatula to mix this up or
how do you do it it's kind of fun to
get in there with your hands so you can
feel what the dough feels like and
should we wash your hands really fast
yeah all right
and you have you just start mixing it
like your hands of spoon exactly we
don't need to mix this for a very long
time we just want to make sure there are
no dry spots and i'm just like squishing
it through my fingers to get rid of the
clumps i don't need any clumps so i'm
going to take my spatula and i'm going
to wipe my hand off did you scrape the
sides of the bowl with the spatula
yeah okay it does a better job
than your hand yeah yeah do you approve
that looks great
yay
cover it with a clean kitchen towel
perfect set it in a warm spot and then
i'm gonna set a 60 minute timer
[Music]
i i missed you so much
um my toe looks
pretty well rested
a little more relaxed on top but other
than that it doesn't look too much
thicker so the next step is to add the
salt and a little bit more water so we
can get that salt incorporated my hands
are clean and i'm gonna dip it in i'm
not being too tender about this like i'm
like really like squishing the dough to
my finger
breaking it up
to try to get the salt in every part of
the dough how do you know when you think
you've incorporated this enough i can't
feel any salt granules on my hands now
we're going to move on to the stretch
and pull so i'm going to dip my hand in
the water i'm going to stretch my dough
up okay and hold it towards the center
and then i'm going to rotate the bowl
i'm going to do that eight times well
this is going to help build like that
tension and help it like puff up totally
right it will help it hold its shape a
little bit more so the last thing we do
after i did the eighth fold i'm going to
wipe both of my hands i'm going to pick
the gel up which is a little scary and
i'm just going to turn it over
and then i like tuck the edges under
clean down the edges of the bowl stick
the clean kitchen towel cover it up put
it in a warm spot and do this of
cleaning it again
[Music]
okay we finally got through those folds
how does yours look mine looks good it's
looking great it's been resting for the
last hour you can see these air bubbles
here i think we're ready to do the
pre-shape great nearby i'm gonna have
some flour
and a bench scraper and if you don't
have a bench scraper we'll just use our
hands now we're just gonna dip our hands
in the water one last time
pick the dough up a little bit
and kind of fold it under itself
and turn it slightly hold it under i'm
pulling it under just by picking it up
and letting gravity
do the work
it's like folding it under itself and
i'm only going to do that like max six
to seven times try to grab it at the
ball and set it right on my table so i'm
going to take a light sprinkling over
the top of my dough
not looking
to totally coat it it's just a light
sprinkler so i'm going to take this and
i'm going to scoop it under the dough
and then drag the dough towards myself
and then i'm going to kind of repeat
that process again and it will help fold
the dough under and make a ball so scoop
under
and drag towards yourself
nice so maybe when you're coming towards
yourself yeah
so so scoop it towards yourself
and then the front part of it
you kind of want to stay put you're not
just trying to move it it's like the
front is staying and you're moving the
back towards it
like that
yeah do you feel that like you could use
it yeah
then i'm like stopping
your left hand to like let it
build build the dough towards yourself
yeah
is that how little totally it's getting
pretty tense now once it's tense and
like pretty round leave that b because
it can rip on the top i'm going to
sprinkle okay more flour cover with my
towel let it rest all this thing does is
rest and we do all the work oh
wow
so we're going to leave this 30 to 40
minutes until it has relaxed and
flattened out
[Music]
okay it's been about 40 minutes let's
take a little peek so the dough is
relaxed a little bit and we're going to
put it into its final shape before we
start touching the dough we want to be
prepared
with our proofing basket which i have
one of those guys
i have one of these as well it has a
little liner sprinkle that lightly with
flour
if you don't have a perfect basket you
can use a glass bowl that's medium sized
lined with a cotton towel make sure it's
not a towel with like terry cloth or
it'll get stuck in the dough so now
would i sprinkle it in right on top of
the dough yeah scrape under it and flip
it over all right here we go
whoa okay let's think of this as a clock
yes i'm gonna bring the 12 o'clock side
and the six o'clock side to the middle
okay and then i'll bring the three
o'clock side and the nine o'clock side
to the middle kind of like we're
wrapping a present almost cute twelve
o'clock and i'm not stretching too much
but i'm going to lightly over the flap
okay oh it is like a present
three o'clock
two corners yeah we'll bring those in
and i'll kind of like pat them down so
they're sealed okay and those two
i'll bring in i'm gonna scoop it up
carefully and place it in pinch these
seams closed
to make sure it's sealed that looks
fabulous katie does it
yeah it's kind of like
we're in the same kitchen making things
i could almost cry at the thought of
being in the same kitchen lightly cover
it with your towel again okay you don't
want the towel to be touching the dough
you're just you're just doing this so it
doesn't get
too much of a skin on it okay so we're
done i'm gonna put this in the fridge
you're gonna put it in your fridge we
will be back tomorrow to bake this i'll
see you tomorrow wait bye
[Music]
it's time to prep our bread yeah let's
do it okay okay so i'm going to take my
parchment paper around
and then i'm going to flip it
yep just just one switch movement right
onto the table confidence
oh yeah yeah
i think okay okay
these looks better
so i'm going to take my hot
combo cooker bottom i will put it on
this cooling rack and then i'm going to
dump my dough and we'll quickly score so
i'm going to use
a breadboard okay which is basically
a razor blade on a stick terrifying i'm
gonna use a paring knife
[Music]
nice okay i'm gonna flip mine yours is
gonna perfectly flip out and mine's not
oh my gosh so i'm going to cut a square
like like kind of a tic tac toe board
i'm gonna go one two
three
four
okay yours
yours is a lot
has a lot more tension than mine for
some reason since mine's already cooking
i'm gonna put it back in the oven oh
nice it's flat
that's okay i mean you can't do anything
about that now okay get it in the oven
[Music]
okay i have my bread marissa
get a cooling rack ready okay so i don't
have a cooling rack so i found i took
this out of a mini toaster that i have i
mean it's just turning back to me
thank you it works it's gonna work
oh
oh it's a beautiful loaf of bread i
think it might be the most pretty one
i've ever made because i made it with
you i'm gonna check mine out okay go get
your bread this is the most exciting
part here's my toasty load
okay your scoring is so much better to
make sure it's done
i'm gonna like tap it and look for like
a hollow sound on the bottom
let's go yeah
oh okay
nice it's like really tempting to cut
into it but if you try to cut into it
now you're gonna kind of like squish it
it's better to let it cool a little bit
at least
it's the final moment marissa i've been
waiting for this okay triumphant music
cue it now
[Music]
i can't get through it okay i think i
got it
wow that was a journey
let's reveal
looks good look at that fermentation oh
look at everyone
[Music]
hmm
that is excellent
so it's soft and squishy on the inside
but it has like a nice
crust if i can make this you guys can
definitely make it follow marissa's
amazing recipe it's super easy and
delicious most importantly
follow her on instagram for much more
bread content and
i don't know mercy how should we sign
off
oh puns baby
[Music]
you